why does the us government want to
censor this
well we've got a lot of i mean i don't
know if it's the government that's
well the government the government works
with these companies like youtube google
i mean we had we had this you know it's
a big issue in the us was the the
censoring of the information about the
hunter biden laptop right
uh
this this was you know the this was
[Music]
an explosive
uh charge which well documented
on the eve of the election
and the tech companies
all of them
blocked the distribution right including
from the new york post's own website
[Music]
wow i mean now that's
but that wasn't done by the government
that was done
by the tech companies on behalf of one
political party or political or one
candidate or one
uh ideology well not ideology but one
one
uh
hate for one one political orientation i
would say
uh
i mean the the the the
the idea that the tech companies
uh
you know and then there was this this
crazy crazy thing where
the
uh a whole group of former intelligence
officials said that
information about the laptop was russian
disinformation when there was no
evidence at all of that
the same people who when they were
confronted with russian disinformation
in the steele dossier didn't recognize
it
uh you know obviously uh this
this creates a real problem but this is
but i think we have to be
clear here these are private companies
that are doing this
and there's a case for
for for taking that power out of their
hands
uh but
uh that doesn't mean that it's the
government that's doing it i'm unaware
for example that the oliver stone
uh document that the action of youtube
against the oliver stone documentary had
anything to do with the government you
know
youtube and google they they they they
uh they're capable of acting on their
own and
these are oftentimes the people who are
the least qualified
to make these judgments
you know the social media has
changed the landscape tremendously
i mean that act of censorship i mean
some people say it changed the outcome
of the election who knows
would it would
a vigorous press
uh
and an absence of so censorship in the
social media
have created a situation in which uh
biden was seen as too corrupted
at least by association to be elected
president well we'll never know the
answer to that question there was the
difference in votes was only 47 000
votes had changed
had changed uh uh
preferences or voters that should had
voted instead
for trump he would have won
so
do you do you think that russia does
meddle in our elections yeah up to a
point but the the the
but it's it doesn't amount to a whole
whole lot i mean they they are just
mostly because they're very you know
they're looking for things to do we do
the same thing in other countries oh
well we've been very we were very active
in the 90s well american citizens in
their private capacity played a huge
role in the russian 1996 election
presidential election how do what do you
mean citizens well consultants private
consultants but with you know great
government connections
who and and also
we
i mean
that's a whole separate story but the
the american you know the agency for
international development we gave aid
you know we we handed out aid to
to political factions that we wanted to
succeed in russia is this the hillary
clinton thing the hillary clinton no no
the this is something different i mean
this is civil societies yeah no this was
this was uh
you know
we we were very pro yeltsin
and we were very concerned that the
communists would win in 1996 and we
we did everything we could to foster
democracy as we saw it in in russia but
in it was
and
you know we instructed people how to
organize votes how to canvas how to
you know
create political ads but all of our good
advice went only to one side
the communists and the leftists who were
more anti-us more anti-western
they uh they were offered the
opportunity
uh to get this information they didn't
react and there was no attempt made to
return their calls you know we we
reacted with relief our people reacted
with relief that that they didn't want
our advice so we were free to
to kind of give
you know useful advice to the other side
but the point the point here is that the
in the in the case of the russian
collusion in the
trump clinton
election which is what a lot of the
discussion is about
it was not so much that they were
interfering although they probably did
interfere to some extent it appears that
they did they did some hacking i was
myself a victim of their hacking really
it was written about yeah
they got into my email
but
but
uh that that we can come to that in a
minute
um
but the real the real
damage that the russians did was
uh by providing the disinformation that
went into the steele dossier
and that was only possible because uh
basically
americans
in this case the clinton campaign were
asking and hungry for that
disinformation
and they and wanted
and and were indifferent to the to the
to its provenance
that's why that happened
not so much that the russians took the
initiative that they reacted to
people who
who
wanted to screw their opponents
and weren't particularly
concerned about the effect it would have
on the country as a whole
well originally this originally the
story was that it was russia meddling
with the election then it changed and
then the focus went to ukraine
and then
and then all the investigations were
going to okay you know ukraine is
meddling with this election this this
was the 2016 trump hillary election and
it was poroshenko who seemed to be very
pro-clinton and anti-trump
during that election i think this is
partially because the the the the
democrats were putting out the idea that
uh that the russians were pro-trump
so the ukrainians reacted by being
pro-clinton
i think there was a lot of confusion on
the part of the ukrainians as to what
was really going on as the
um
they may have fallen victims
of uh
of russia's propaganda and and the
democratic party's propaganda because
they may have overestimated the extent
to which
trump would be uh
uh you know a tool in the hands of the
russians i mean it was trump that
authorized the javelin missiles not
obama right
yeah you know there when it comes to
trump the hysteria becomes such that any
kind of objective discussion and he
stokes it no he contributes to it
but but you know there's we have a
situation in this country in which
uh
the his the level of hysteria is such
that
looking at
trump and what he
did do and did not do and evaluating it
objectively is just
not possible for people right